Variety magazine just released
Hollywood's top star salaries and listen
to me the numbers will blow your mind
Robert Downey jr. will make 20 million
for the voyage of dr. Dolittle the same
reported bass he earned for Avengers and
game while gal gadot will only make half
that for her sequel Wonder Woman 1984
Dwayne Johnson one of Hollywood's
highest-paid stars made an estimated 124
million last year this year he has
several movies in the works and will
pocket 20 million alone for his fast and
furious spin-off Hobson Shah but as
varieties money issue points out the
biggest paycheck seemed to be coming
from Netflix projects Ryan Reynolds will
earn 27 million for the streaming
thriller six underground that's more
than he made for doing both Deadpool
movies combined and Will Smith his king
of the list
he's expected to rake in 35 million for
doing bright - for Netflix certainly
wait for the cavalry we are the cavalry
still not everyone's cleaning up many
stars are now choosing to take a smaller
salary upfront in favor of taking a cut
of the film's actual profits once
released Tom Cruise who once commanded
20 million per movie will make between
12 and 14 million for the Top Gun sequel
Brad Pitt and Leonardo DiCaprio slashed
their rake to ten million apiece to work
with Quentin Tarantino on Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood
while Joaquin Phoenix is getting paid
4.5 million for the Joker
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]